This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。欢迎收看Look Back at it播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个大时刻。对84年我印象也很深。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而退》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《知难而退》。2023年，黄金单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
这就是在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Before we get started, this episode of the podcast does contain references and discussions of child abuse. If this is a sensitive topic for you, please reflect on whether you are ready to listen to this episode. If you don't feel ready, it will still be here in a week, a month, a year, whenever it's a better time to listen. Take care of yourselves and I'm sending you love and healing. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so lovely, so great to have you. you hear back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在我们开始之前，本期播客确实包含关于虐待儿童的参考和讨论。如果这对你来说是一个敏感话题，请反思一下你是否准备好收听这一期节目。如果你觉得还没准备好，它依然会在这里，一周后、一个月后、一年后，无论什么时候觉得更适合收听都可以。照顾好你们自己，我向你们发送爱与治愈。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴，太棒了你能来到这里。欢迎收听新的一期节目，当然，我们一如既往地剖析我们20多岁的心理学。
This week when I sat down at my desk and I was deciding what to talk about this week, what did I want to discuss? I made the decision to do something a little bit fun, a little bit different. I wanted to do an episode that you might not think has anything to do with psychology. You know, I feel like we've done quite a few serious, emotional, very in-depth, somewhat scientific episodes as of late and I wanted to kind of do something a bit more fun one topic that kept floating to the surface for me was tattoos why do we get them not just in our 20s but at any stage how important are they to our identity which tattoos do we end up regretting which ones do we not end up regretting basically I want to talk about the psychology of tattoos and that my friends
这周当我坐在桌前，决定这周聊点什么时，我想讨论什么呢？我决定做一点有趣、一点不同的事情。我想做一个你可能觉得与心理学完全无关的节目。你知道，我觉得我们最近做了一些严肃、感人、非常深入且有点科学性的节目，而我想要做一些更有趣的事情。有一个话题一直浮现在我的脑海中，那就是纹身。我们为什么要去纹身？不仅仅是在20多岁，而是在任何阶段？它们对我们的身份有多重要？我们最终会后悔哪些纹身？哪些纹身又不会后悔？基本上，我想聊聊纹身的心理学，而我的朋友们，
is what we are going to do today I have been endless fascinated by this topic for some time as someone with tattoos, I have never actually considered why I got them. Why was I called to literally get something permanently put on my body when I had just turned 18? Why did I decide on specific designs? Why did I decide on what to get? What was the motivation? And in thinking about my own intentions with my tattoos, I uncovered so much research that I did not even know was out there. I also talked to some of my friends. I'm so lucky to have some incredible friends in my life who are tattoo artists
这就是我们今天要做的。一段时间以来，我对这个话题一直着迷不已。作为一个有纹身的人，我实际上从未深究过我为什么要去纹身。为什么我刚满18岁时，就被召唤着要在我的身体上永久地刻上些东西？为什么我决定采用特定的设计？为什么我决定要纹这个？背后的动机是什么？在思考我对纹身的初心时，我发现了大量我甚至不知道存在的相关研究。我还和一些朋友聊过。我很幸运，生命中有一些非常了不起的朋友，他们是纹身师，
and who make a living off of permanent art on somebody else's body. Like there is no other type of art like it. And I spoke to them and I was like, can you tell me what you hear from people who are getting tattoos? Are you seeing a specific kind of person get a specific kind of tattoo? to do people ever come back and say they regret it? Like, tell me about the emotional experience you have with a client when you are putting something on their body.
并且以在别人身体上创作永久艺术为生。就像没有其他类型的艺术能与之相比。我和他们交谈过，我说，你能告诉我，你在那些来纹身的人身上都听到了什么吗？你是否看到某种特定的人会去纹某种特定的纹身？人们事后会回来表示后悔吗？比如，能跟我讲讲当你把东西纹在客户身体上时，你与他们之间的情感体验吗？
And it has just been so fascinating talking to people about what kind of feels like quite an innocuous subject. I also found this interesting piece of research saying that the majority of people who have tattoos got their first one in their 20s. Now, you may hear that and think. that Gemma that makes sense right depending on where you live most people can't get tattoos before they turn 18 and even then you probably don't have the money to get the tattoos that you want until you're in your 20s so it feels like the time a lot of people are doing it but it also comes down
与人们谈论这个感觉相当无害的主题，实在是太迷人了。我还发现了一项有趣的研究，表明拥有纹身的绝大多数人都是在20多岁时纹了第一个纹身。现在，你听到可能会想，杰玛，这说得通，对吧？取决于你住在哪里，大多数人在18岁之前是不能纹身的，即便到了那时，你可能也没有钱去纹你想要的纹身，直到你20多岁。所以这感觉像是很多人都在做的年龄段，但它也归结于
to the fact that this decade is when we are in peak identity formation season we've had our teen years to really explore but it's our 20s where we are really trying to find the shoe or the outfit or the persona that fits. We are trying to find our space. We are really starting to feel grounded in who we are. We're kind of exploring different facets of our identity. And sometimes that calls for expression. It calls for something permanent to represent who we are and what we're going through.
这样一个事实：这个十年正是我们身份形成的巅峰时期。我们度过了青少年时期来进行真正的探索，但在20多岁时，我们才真正努力寻找适合自己的那双鞋、那套衣服或那个人设。我们正在努力寻找自己的空间。我们真正开始对自己的身份感到踏实。我们开始探索自己身份的不同方面。有时这需要一种表达。它需要一些永久性的东西来代表我们是谁以及我们正在经历什么。
That is where tattoos come in. And I think of tattoos kind of as like a testimony to the age you are when you get them. and maybe in 10, 20 years time, you'll look at it and think, what was I thinking? Like, what does this even mean? But maybe it's also, you know, an important right of passage to some people. It brings a sense of certainty. All right, I don't want to spoil the entire episode before we even get into it. But really what we are going to do today is just take a big bite into all the fascinating research to do with body modification,
这就是纹身登场的地方。我认为纹身有点像你纹身时所处年龄的见证。也许在10年、20年后，你会看着它想，我当时在想什么？这到底是什么意思？但也许，对某些人来说，这也是一个重要的成人仪式。它带来了一种确定感。好吧，我不想在还没开始之前就剧透整期节目。但实际上我们今天要做的，只是深入探讨所有与身体改造相关的迷人研究，
tattooing, even things like regret, as well as do a brief kind of dive into some of the history as well because this topic has so many dimensions to it. Without further ado, my lovely listeners, let us get into the psychology of tattoos. Let's talk briefly about the history of tattoos because I feel like the change in attitudes that we've experienced just in the last 50 years is really quite striking and worth investigating. Now, I always get in trouble when I talk about history on this podcast because there are some very smart people out there who know a lot more about very specific topics than me
纹身，甚至包括诸如后悔之类的事情，同时也会简要回顾一下历史，因为这个话题有太多的维度。废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，让我们进入纹身的心理学。让我们简要谈谈纹身的历史，因为我觉得我们在过去50年里经历的态度转变确实非常显著，值得探讨。现在，每当我在这个播客里谈论历史时，我总是会惹上麻烦，因为外面有一些非常聪明的人，他们对非常特定主题的了解比我多得多，
and very graciously correct me when I'm wrong. But I really did a deep dive into this one. I used what I think is like the mother of all guides, the Smithsonian's worldwide history of tattoos, to really go in deep. So I hope that you are all prepared for a bit of a factual start to this episode. Some people will incorrectly assume or tell you that tattoos first emerged in the 1800s. That cannot be further from the truth.
并且在我犯错时非常风度翩翩地纠正我。但我确实对这个话题进行了深入研究。我使用了我认为是所有指南之母的史密森尼学会全球纹身史来深入挖掘。所以我希望你们都为这期节目带有事实基础的开端做好准备。有些人会错误地假设或告诉你纹身最早出现在19世纪。这与事实相去甚远。
Humans have been marking their skin in ritualistic and important ways for literally thousands of years. Around the world, across different cultures, tattoos are. are really, really significant. I think about, you know, the Greeks, they used to use tattoos to declare love. Indigenous Polynesians used to use tattoos to tell personal stories. We see them in ancient Serbian nomads in Native South Americans. Tattoos have this real core place in the human story, how we express ourselves, how we signify status, religious, beliefs even as just purely a form of decoration. So I think what people generally used to believe is
人类以仪式感和重要的方式在皮肤上做标记，已经有数千年的历史了。在世界各地，跨越不同的文化，纹身都具有非常非常重大的意义。我想，你知道，古希腊人过去常常用纹身来宣示爱情。原住民波利尼西亚人过去常常用纹身来讲述个人故事。我们在古代塞尔维亚游牧民族和美洲原住民身上也能看到它们。纹身在人类的故事中占据着真正核心的地位，关乎我们如何表达自己，如何彰显地位、宗教信仰，甚至纯粹作为一种装饰形式。所以我想人们过去普遍认为，
that it was the Egyptians who were like these so-called inventors of inking skin and they used to use different kinds of pigments or ground up insects and they would insert the, you know, wet pigment into the skin using a piece of bronze or like a sharp stick. There's also evidence of a very famous mummy. It's called Otsey the Iceman. If you're a history buff you'll know this mummy quite well. That individual is almost 6,000 years old and when they found
是埃及人成为了所谓的皮肤刺青发明者，他们过去使用各种颜料或碾碎的昆虫，然后用一块青铜或锋利的棍子将湿润的颜料刺入皮肤。还有一个关于非常著名的木乃伊的证据。它被称为冰人奥茨。如果你是个历史迷，你会对这个木乃伊非常熟悉。那个个体几乎有6000年的历史，当他们发现
this mummified person, he had tattoos 6,000 years ago. People were already adorning their skin. Now that is really the beginning of tattoos as we know it. Let's now go forward about 5,700 years, 300 years ago. During this time, specifically in Western cultures, something changed when it came to our attitudes towards tattoos. They used to be very culturally, maybe religiously significant.
这个木乃伊化的人时，他身上就有纹身。6000年前，人们就已经在装饰自己的皮肤了。现在，这才是我们所知的纹身的真正开始。让我们现在快进大约5700年，来到300年前。在此期间，特别是在西方文化中，当我们对纹身的态度发生改变时，有些事情变了。它们曾经具有非常深厚的文化甚至宗教意义。
And then they started being considered a sign of being a criminal or a deviant. They're associated with gangs, with behaviors that society doesn't approve of. And as such, they're banned in some spaces. Actually, I remember visiting Japan last year and not being able to enter the onsense or the hot baths because I had tattoos. So it's still relevant in some cultures. But we can link a lot of this stigma back to a specific group of Christian missionaries who did a really great job at convincing people back then that tattoos would disfigure the sacred. vessel given to us by God. And consequently, they were banned.
然后它们开始被认为是罪犯或叛逆者的标志。它们与帮派、与社会不赞同的行为联系在一起。因此，它们在某些空间里被禁止。实际上，我记得去年访问日本时，因为身上有纹身，无法进入温泉或热浴池。所以在某些文化中它仍然很重要。但我们可以将这种污名的大部分归咎于一群基督教传教士，他们在当时把人们洗脑得很好，让人坚信纹大会玷污上帝赐予我们的神圣器皿。因此，它们被禁止了。
They were banned in Christianity. And as Christianity became more widespread, that same belief was impressed upon different cultures, some of whom did have a historical, I don't know, a historical attachment to tattooing. Of course, we know that did not stop people from doing it, but it did bring about. a stigma that if you got tattoos, you were obviously not a god-fearing individual. And therefore, you were probably up to no good. This is how they really became associated with being, you know, a bit of a rebel.
它们在基督教中被禁止了。随着基督教的普及，同样的信仰也被强加给不同的文化，其中一些文化原本确实有历史上的、我不知道，有历史上的纹身传统。当然，我们知道这并没有阻止人们这样做，但它确实带来了一种污名：如果你有纹身，你显然不是一个敬畏上帝的人。因此，你可能在图谋不轨。这就是它们如何真正与成为一个有点叛逆的人联系在一起的。
And they became associated with criminality and counterculture. But around like the 1940s, specifically in America, there was a revival of tattooing in Western cultures. And slowly more and more people knew someone with a tattoo. They knew a relative. They knew someone in the army. Then, you know, they kind of thought about getting one of their own. They have kids with tattoos. So nowadays, there's some estimates that between 30 to 48% of people in the countries
它们与犯罪和反主流文化联系在了一起。但在20世纪40年代左右，特别是在美国，西方文化的纹身复兴了。渐渐地，越来越多的人认识有纹身的人。他们认识某个亲戚。他们认识军队里的人。然后，你知道，他们有点考虑自己也去纹一个。他们有了纹身的孩子。所以如今，据估计，在
surveyed for countries like Canada, America, Germany and Australia, those were the countries included in these studies. 30 to 48% of people in those countries have tattoos. Now, if you're in your 20s, the likelihood that you have a tattoo is increased. It's around 38 to 52%. So that's showing that, like, over time, generationally, we have become a lot more accepting and we're a lot more normal about this idea. I remember before I got my first tattoo, I was like, still had this, like, fear of not being
接受调查的国家（如加拿大、美国、德国和澳大利亚，这些国家都包含在这些研究中）中，有30%到48%的人拥有纹身。那些国家中有30%到48%的人有纹身。现在，如果你正处于20多岁，你拥有纹身的可能性会增加。大约在38%到52%之间。这表明，随着时间的推移，从代际来看，我们变得更加包容，对这种想法也更加习以为常了。我记得在我纹第一个纹身之前，我依然有一种恐惧，害怕找不到工作，
able to find a job specifically, like, if it was visible. but nowadays, like the stigma has definitely lessened. So there's your little history lesson for the day. I know this is a psychology podcast. I will not dwell on it for long. But I do think it's important to cover because that attitudinal change does play into the psychology behind why we may be drawn to get a tattoo. All right, let's talk about that question now.
特别是如果纹身露在外面。但如今，这种污名绝对减轻了。这就是你们今天的微型历史课。我知道这是一个心理学播客。我不会在这上面逗留太久。但我认为把它涵盖进来很重要，因为这种态度的转变确实对我们为什么会被吸引去纹身背后的心理学起到了作用。好了，让我们现在来谈谈那个问题。
Why? Why do we feel compelled to put something permanent on our eyes? skin. So when it comes down to it when you're sitting in that tattoo chair, when you're waiting for the needle to go in, you are probably in that position because of one of four reasons. The first is that you're looking to represent something of personal emotional significance on your body. This is a way of telling your personal story and your personal beliefs and maybe reaffirming to yourself what you care about, what's important to you. Is it family? Is it religion? Is it a specific value system? One of the largest studies ever done on the psychology of tattoos was conducted
为什么？为什么我们感到非得在我们的皮肤上留下一处永久的痕迹不可。归根结底，当你坐在那张纹身椅上，当你等待针扎进来时，你之所以处于那个位置，大概是出于以下四个原因之一。第一个原因是，你希望在身上展现某种具有个人情感意义的事物。这是讲述你的个人故事和个人信仰的一种方式，也许是在向自己重申你在乎什么、什么对你是重要的。是家庭？是宗教？还是特定的价值观？有史以来关于纹身心理学的最大规模研究之一是在南非对19岁到35岁的大学生进行的。
in South Africa with university students between 19 and 35. Now, some of them had tattoos, some of them were considering it. Some of them were just like absolutely not at all. And the researchers said explain your reasoning and then they thematically grouped the responses. Now, amongst people who had a tattoo or wanted a tattoo, 25% of them said, the reason I would want to do it is because this thing has a personal meaning. It marks a significant experience or struggle for me. So some of the reasons given were I got a tattoo to honor my mother, to honor my siblings because it represents my life philosophy because this really presents what I was going through it at a certain time in my life and I want to remember it. This idea is one I actually really
现在，他们中的一些人有纹身，一些人正在考虑纹身。还有一些人则是绝对完全不考虑。研究人员说请解释你的理由，然后他们对回答进行了主题分类。现在，在拥有纹身或想要纹身的人当中，有25%的人说，我之所以想这么做，是因为这东西有个人意义。它对我来说标志着一段重大的经历或挣扎。所以给出的一些理由包括：我纹身是为了纪念我的母亲，为了纪念我的兄弟姐妹，因为它代表了我的生活哲学，因为这真实呈现了我人生某一特定阶段所经历的事情，我想记住它。这个想法是我实际上非常想抓住并探讨一下的，那就是纹身可以带来一种持久感。它们真的可以把我们锚定在特定的时间和我们的身份、感受以及我们在那一刻所经历的事情上。这就好比如果我把这个纹在身上，这段经历将永远是我的一部分。我不会忘记。我不会忘记那个挚爱的人。我不会忘记我是多么有能力，我是多么勇敢地熬过了一段经历。我永远不会忘记这就是我看待生活的方式。这就是我选择生活的方式。所以如果我们的身体只是灵魂的一个容器，你知道，为什么不以对你重要的方式来装饰它呢？我发现这个理由，这种几乎把你的身体当成日记的做法非常引人入胜。我身上有自己人生特定时期的纹身，
want to grab onto for a second and it's the idea that tattoos can bring about a sense of permanence. They can really anchor us to a specific time and our identity and our feelings and what we were going through in that moment. It's kind of like if I put this on my body, this experience will always be part of me. I won't forget. I won't forget that loved one. I won't forget how capable I was and how courageous I was to get through an experience. I'll never forget that this is how I see life. This is how I choose to live it. So if our body is just a vessel for our soul, you know, why not decorate? it in the in the manner of what is important to you i find this reason this reasoning almost using your body like a journal in some ways quite compelling i have tattoos from specific periods in my life
每当我想到它们，我都能准确地记起我当时正在经历什么，是什么让我相信这件事情很重要，必须要去纹一个。其中有一个特别的纹身，我向非常非常少的人承认过，这是一个失恋纹身。我18岁时经历了一次失恋，那真的糟透了。我不知道，它就是被笼罩在很多，我不知道，它是复杂的。我只能说它是复杂的。作为我的第一次重大心碎，它教会了我很多。我记得当时有一种强烈的独立感，
and when i think about them i can exactly remember what i was going through that made me believe that this thing was important to get one in particular and i have admitted this to this to very, very few people is a breakup tattoo. I went through this like breakup when I was 18 and it was really awful. And I don't know, it was just, it was shrouded in a lot of, I don't know, it was complex. I'll just say it was complex. And being my first like big heartbreak, it taught me a lot. And I remember having this resounding sense of like independence.
就像无论如何你都必须独立，你必须能够依靠自己，你不能依附于任何一个人。所以我纹了这个代表这一点的纹身。现在我有了更平衡的视角，但有时当我照镜子看到那个纹身时，我能准确地记起我在哪里得到了它，我指的不只是我当时在物理上的位置，还有情绪上和精神上的位置。22岁纹身也是如此，你知道，我在2002年2月22日迎来了22岁生日，这对我来说意义重大，感觉非常契合，感觉这是需要被留住的东西，而且你知道，坦白说，我22岁的那一年是我人生的神奇一年——我辞了工作，遇到了男友，终于在我所在的城市感到了快乐，
like no matter what you need to be independent you need to be able to rely on yourself you cannot get attached to any one person and so i got this like tattoo that represented that and now i have a more balanced perspective but when i look at that tattoo in the mirror sometimes i can exactly remember where i was when i got it and i don't just mean physically where i was but emotionally and mentally as well same for like my 22 tattoo you know I turned 22 on the 22nd of the second 2002 that felt very significant to me it felt very aligned it felt like it was something that needed to be held on to and you know actually quite frankly like my 22nd year was an amazing year of my life like I quit my job I met my boyfriend I finally felt happy in the city I was in
我得到了所有这些机会，但是，你知道，我有时确实还是会看着它想，你为什么非要纹那个？为什么，为什么你非要纹那个，因为你已经不再22岁了？但我想我们稍后会聊聊后悔。在那一刻对我来说最大的原因是我当时所处位置的情感意义。对其他人来说，这也是非常重要的。它真的归结于自我身份认同，以及我们渴望抓住那些塑造了我们的感受和相遇的愿望，甚至可能把我们的身体当作一种方式来传达我们是谁以及我们经历过什么。我想把哈利波特纹身作为这方面的完美例子，或者任何粉丝群体或宗教纹身。这些被称为群体认同纹身。你知道，
I had all these opportunities, but, you know, I do still sometimes look at it and be like, why did you have to get that? Why, why did you have to get that because you're not 22 anymore? But I think we'll talk about regret a little bit later. The biggest reason for me in that moment was the emotional significance of where I was. And for other people, that's really important as well. It really comes down to self-identity and our desire to hold onto the feelings and encounters that have shaped us, perhaps even using our body as like a way to communicate who we are and what we've experienced. I think about Harry Potter tattoos as a perfect example of this or any kind of fandom or religious tattoo. These are called group identification tattoos. You know,
你在身上纹点东西，这样如果别人看到了，也许他们就能含蓄地知道你是什么样的人，或者如果他们是对同样事物感兴趣的人，他们就会想，哦，朋友，我懂你，我知道你是谁，我们有这个共同点，尽管我们从未谋面。这就像是一种沟通、认同或归属的形式。这是一种归属感。这是一种归属感。当然，如果人们利用仇恨符号作为识别他们所属群体的方式，这也可能会急转直下，变成一件可怕的事情。这就是这种哲学被推向非常消极、黑暗的极端的例子。但它仍然是某些人纹身动机的一部分。
you put something on your body so that if someone else saw it, they would know maybe implicitly what kind of person you are or if they were someone who was interested in the same things they could be like oh friend you know i know who you are we have this thing in common even though we've never met it's like this form of communication or recognition belonging it's a form of belonging it's a form of belonging obviously that can also take a terrible term if people are using hate symbols as a way to identify a group to which they belong. Like that's this, that's this philosophy taken to a very negative, dark extreme. But it is still part of some people's motivations for getting tattoos.
出于价值观而纹身的最后一个原因可能是基于文化原因。正如我们已经解释过的，有许多文化拥有令人惊叹的纹身历史。我想到了我们在澳大利亚的邻居新西兰毛利人，他们会纹——我试着正确发音这个词——Tā moko，这是传统的毛利纹身，真正象征着文化自豪感、历史和故事。它们可以标志着重大的场合，比如婚礼或毕业。顺便说一句，我需要你们去查查人们是如何得到这些纹身的，因为当我第一次看到这个过程时，我真的觉得，哇，这些人是地球上最硬核的人。是的，这就是召唤人们在皮肤上留下永久印记的很大一部分原因。让我们谈谈我们纹身的第二个原因，
The final value-based reason for getting a tattoo can be for cultural reasons. As we've already explained, there are so many cultures with an amazing history of tattooing. I think about our New Zealand and Maori neighbors here in Australia who get, I'm going to try and pronounce this right, Samoko, which is traditional Maori tattoos that really symbolize cultural pride, history, story. They can mark like a significant occasion, like a marriage or a graduation. Side note, I need you to look up how people get these tattoos because when I first saw that process, I genuinely was like, wow, These are the toughest people on the planet. But yes, that is a really big part of what calls people to have something permanent on their skin. Let's talk about the second reason we get tattoos,
那就是因为它只是一种迷人的艺术形式。它是我们通过装饰对身份的延伸。现在，第一个原因非常深刻。它是非常基于身份认同的。这个原因就没有那么深。纹身很漂亮。我们只是一块画布。我们的身体就是为了被装饰而造的。就这么简单。你的纹身不需要有特定的意义。
and that is because it's just an appealing form of art. It's an extension of our identity through decoration. Now, the first reason was very deep. It's very identity-based. This one is less deep. Tattoos are pretty. We are just a canvas. our body is made to be adorned. Simple as that. Your tattoos don't need a specific meaning.
实际上，在最近的一期节目中，一位嘉宾跟我提起她的一位朋友，每当她有这种感觉时就会去纹一些随意的纹身。你知道，她我想大概50多岁了，她会在周六走进一家纹身店然后说，来吧，给我装饰一下。你知道，如果她看到一个酷炫的卡通片，一个她喜欢的词，一个图像，一个图案，她就这么做。我认为那。我认为那，是思考我们身体以及思考它在这个世界上的永恒或缺乏永恒的一种美丽方式。不过，当涉及到这一点时，我总是纠结的一点，或者当我纠结于“我应该纹一个特定的纹身吗？我应该选择一个特定的设计吗”时，我内心的辩论是：我觉得这很可爱，只是因为它是一个潮流设计吗？这不就跟一件病毒式传播的毛衣或者一支病毒式的润唇膏一样吗，但它却要永远留在我的身体上。这是我经常考虑的事情。如果纹身是自我表达，为什么我们很多人最后都会纹相似的纹身呢？比如我能想到的例子，大家都喜欢在手指上纹爱心纹身，就像在2015、2016年左右那样，还有无限符号纹身。现在则是微型纹身。男孩纹身，我觉得这真的非常非常可爱。每个人以前都在手指上纹的那只狮子纹身。这些都不是天生糟糕的纹身，但有趣的是，我们很多人
In a recent episode, actually, a guest was telling me about a friend of hers who gets random tattoos whenever she feels like it. You know, she's, I think, in her 50s and she'll go into a tattoo parlor on a Saturday and just say, go for it, decorate me. You know, if she sees a cool cartoon, a word she loves, an image, a pattern, she just does it. I think that it. I think that, is a beautiful way to think about our body and to think about, you know, it's permanence or lack of permanence in this world. Something I do always struggle with when it comes to this though, or I debate with myself when it comes to, should I get a specific tattoo? Should I get a specific design is, do I just think this is cute because it's a trending design? Is this just the same as a viral
在同一时间都去纹了它们。我认为这反映的是一种共同审美品味、共同的文化潮流，当然还有社群认同。你知道，互联网显然——互联网的某些部分就是一个社群。所以我们都会对同样的事物感到兴奋。我们最终在相同的事物中发现美。我认为就像艺术总体上有不同的季节和流派一样，比如抽象艺术、文艺复兴、当代艺术，纹身也会经历这样的季节，这意味着很多人会随波逐流。现在，老实说，我不认为这是一件坏事。就像我认为，仅仅因为你觉得某样东西很美，而别人也觉得那很美，并不意味着
sweater or a viral lip balm, but it is going to be on my body forever. That's something I consider a lot. If tattoos are self-expression, why is it that a lot of us end up getting similar tattoos? Like some examples I can think of the love heart tattoos. Everyone was getting on their fingers, like back in like 2015, 2016, Infinity tattoos. Now it's like micro tattoos. boy tattoos, which I think are really, really cute. That lion tattoo that everyone used to get on their finger. None of these are inherently bad tattoos, but it's interesting that a lot of us
你就不独特了。我实际上觉得，当我看到有人有这些纹身时，我会想，哇，你简直就是我们生活的文化和时代的挂毯。你知道，你是历史的一部分。这其实相当酷，你的身体上有这样一件东西，我知道这听起来有点病态，但假设在3000年后有人把你挖出来，就像我们讨论过的那个木乃伊一样，他们发现你手指上有一个心的纹身。他们会说，哦，哇，那在当时一定很重要。
got them at the same time. And I think what it reflects is like a shared aesthetic appreciation, shared cultural trends, community identity, of course. And you know, the internet is obviously, some parts of the internet are a community. So we all kind of feel excited by the the same things. We end up finding beauty in the same things. I think just like art in general has different seasons and movements like abstract art, the Renaissance, contemporary art, tattoos go through these kind of seasons as well and it means that a lot of people will jump on the bandwagon. Now, I don't think this is a bad thing quite honestly. Like I think just because you find something beautiful and someone else also finds that beautiful, does it mean that?
那在当时一定是对人们具有审美意义的东西。我发现这非常非常有趣。好了，我们要稍作休息，因为我马上要转换话题了。但当我回来时，让我们来谈谈纹身在应对、从创伤中恢复方面的作用，以及这种做法是否真的会成瘾。所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。《2%》。
mean you are not unique. I actually think that when I see someone with these tattoos, I'm like, wow, you are kind of a tapestry for the culture and age that we're living in. You know, this is, you're a part of history. Like, this is actually quite cool that you have this thing on your body that I know this is quite morbid, but say someone was to dig you up in 3,000 years like that mummy we talked about and they found like a tattoo of a heart on your finger. they could say, oh, wow, that must have been important at the time.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
That must have been something that was aesthetic to people at the time. And I find that very, very interesting. Okay, we are going to take a quick break because I'm fully about to shift gears here. But when I return, let's talk about the role of tattooing in coping, healing from trauma, and whether this practice can actually become addictive. All of that and so much more. after this short break. 2%.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开交流，看透主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness
剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要。仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。
industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It Podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here,
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而退》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你喜爱的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me. just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同信任水平。我希望你纯粹只是去做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而退》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
打开免费的Our Heart Radio应用。搜索《知难而退》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年，前黄金单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
埃伦斯女士，你对某个人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，那个女同性恋者，还有迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway. hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, and Michael Marantini.
这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona.
就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games,
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。几年前，我偶然读到一篇文章，作者自称为“墨水护士”（ink nurse），他们谈到了“墨水疗法”或“纹身疗法”的概念。本质上，她的观点是，我们在情感和精神上感受到的一切，无法单靠心灵去消解。它也需要通过身体来处理。现在，对某些人来说，情绪是通过眼泪和悲伤来处理的，也许还有
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
愤怒、锻炼、创作艺术。对其他人来说，他们处理创伤、心理痛苦、心碎，以及人类灵魂经历过的任何事情的方式，就是通过纹身。为什么会这样呢？首先，我认为是因为纹身给了我们一种在日常生活中可能缺乏的掌控感。通过这种方式，你知道，你有这种巨大的力量对你的身体做你想做的事，它真的可以通过向外界描绘对你重要、你觉得有趣或你觉得美丽的事物，来帮助你夺回你的身份主权。你在说，我对我的身体拥有完全的所有权。所以这就是我要对它做的事。我想谈谈一项真正能说明这一点的研究。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. few years ago, I came across an article by someone calling themselves an ink nurse, and they talked about this idea of ink or tattoo therapy. Essentially, her take was that everything we feel emotionally and mentally cannot disappear through the mind alone. It also needs to be processed by the body. Now, for some people, emotions are processed through tears and grief, maybe.
谈到这种夺回主权以及纹身的强大治愈力，这项研究实际上探讨了童年虐待和忽视与拥有纹身和穿孔可能性之间的联系。它在德国进行，有1000多名参与者，他们确实发现纹身和穿孔在报告曾遭受童年虐待和忽视的个人中更为常见。所以他们将这种极其深的情感痛苦与装饰和对待我们身体的方式联系起来。
rage, exercise, making art. For others, the way they process trauma, psychological pain, heartache, anything that the human soul has kind of gone through is through tattoos. Why is this the case? Well, firstly, I think it's because tattoos give us a sense of control we may be lacking in our ordinary life. In this way, you know, you have this immense power to do to your body what you wish to do with it and it can really help you reclaim your identity by making it your own through an outward depiction of what matters to you or what you find interesting or what you find beautiful. You're saying, I have complete ownership over my body. So this is what I'm going to do with it. I want to talk about one piece of research that really speaking.
现在他们得出的另一个结论是，在这个意义上的身体改造实际上对这些人来说是一次非常赋能的经历，因为尽管他们遭受了巨大的逆转，他们现在正在夺回控制权。而且还有一个与疼痛有关的奇异感觉，让这种疼痛自残实际上相当赋能，相比于过去疼痛被用来对付他们的时候。这具有深刻的心理学意义。对我来说，这个解释非常有道理。这些发现在另一项研究中得到了证实。在稍后发表的另一
to this reclaiming and this powerful healing of tattoos in particular, this piece of research actually looked at the association between childhood abuse and neglect without likelihood of getting tattoos and piercings. It was conducted in Germany with over a thousand participants, and they did find tattoos and piercings more common amongst individuals who reported childhood abuse and neglect. So they're linking this very deep emotional suffering with a way of adorning and treating our bodies.
项研究中，这些研究人员谈到了我们对特定纹身甚至纹身本身的渴望，实际上让我们得以窥见某个人的内心世界。他们选择在身上纹什么，实际上是一个非常——我不想再用“有趣”这个词了——但这是一种非常隐秘、几乎深入的方式，来理解他们经历过什么以及他们是如何看待世界的。所以这篇论文发表于2017年，它实际上讨论了治疗师如何利用患者的纹身来引发与他们的开放讨论，询问他们的纹身，询问他们的含义、纹身的动机，以此作为与客户实现突破的一种方式。
Now what they also concluded is that body modification in the sense was actually a very empowering experience for these people because although they had suffered this great adversity, they were now taking back the control. And there was also this weird sense relating to pain and letting that pain be self-inflicted was actually quite empowering compared to times when pain had been used against them. It's deeply psychological. And to me, this explanation makes a lot of sense. And these findings have been corroborated. In another
他们得出的另一个结论是，从某种意义上说，身体改造对这些人来说实际上是一次非常赋能的经历，因为尽管他们遭遇了巨大的逆苦，但他们现在重新掌握了控制权。而且还有一种关于痛苦的奇妙感觉，让痛苦由自己施加，与过去痛苦被用来对付他们的时候相比，实际上相当具有赋能作用。这有着很深的心理学根源。对我来说，这种解释非常合情合理。而且这些发现在另一
piece of research that was published, just a little bit later on, these researchers talk about how our desire to get specific tattoos or even to get tattoos at all actually gives us a real peak, a real vision into someone's psyche. What they choose to get on their body is actually a really, I don't know, I don't want to say interesting again, but it's a very secretive, almost in-depth way of understanding what they've been through and how they see the world. So this paper, this was published in 2017, it actually talks about how therapists can prompt an open discussion with someone using their tattoos, asking them about their tattoos, asking them about their meaning, their motivations for getting them as a way to kind of have a breakthrough with a client.
随后不久发表的研究中得到了证实。这些研究人员谈到，我们渴望纹上特定的图案，甚至渴望去纹身的愿望，实际上让我们得以一窥某人的心理。他们选择纹在身上的东西，实际上是一种非常——我不知道，我不想再用“有趣”这个词了——但这是一种非常隐秘、几乎是深入的方式，让人了解他们经历过什么以及他们如何看待世界。因此，这篇发表于2017年的论文实际上探讨了治疗师如何通过利用某人的纹身来引发开放式的讨论，询问他们的纹身、纹身的意义以及他们纹身的动机，以此作为与客户取得突破的一种方式。
basically if someone has a specific piece of art it's obviously important enough for them to have put it on their body so there must have been some motivation that has caused them to think that this is a good idea and that this is what they want what is that motivation linked to what can that tell you about who they are as a person not only that not only is it linked to control not only is it linked to personality tattoos have also been shown to change how we think about our bodies. Having that control and being able to make ourselves into a form of art is so mentally powerful if you are someone who struggles with things like body dysmorphia or just general unhappiness towards your appearance. There have been some studies including a specific one I'm thinking about from 2011 that showed that right after getting a tattoo,
基本上，如果有人有一件特定的艺术品，这显然对他们很重要，以至于他们把它纹在身上，所以肯定有一些动机促使他们认为这是一个好主意，并且这就是他们想要的，这个动机和什么有关？这能说明他们是一个什么样的人？不仅如此，它不仅与控制力有关，不仅与个性有关，纹身还被证明会改变我们对自己身体的看法。拥有这种控制力，能够把我们自己变成一种艺术形态，在精神上是非常强大的，如果你是一个与身体异形恐惧症或对自己的外表感到普遍不快乐等问题作斗争的人。有一些研究，包括我正在想的2011年的一项具体研究表明，在纹身后不久，
individuals reportedly feel better about their bodies they experience less appearance-based anxiety and they also express less fear of being perceived in that kind of way tattoos are like a psychological armor and for that reason they also influence our emotional state so our emotional state influences whether we get them and then once we do get them that has a further impact it's like a cycle that is why tattoos can become addictive because the process of getting them makes us feel some sort of way. Anything that changes our mood such that we associate an activity with immediately feeling better has the capacity to become addictive. You know, alcohol, for example, makes us feel less anxious and more lively, that emotional association makes it addictive. Enphetamines give us that huge rush, make us feel joyous.
据报道，个人对自己的身体感觉更好，他们经历的基于外表的焦虑减少了，他们也表达了对以这种方式被看待的恐惧减少了。纹身就像是一种心理盔甲，正因为如此，它们也会影响我们的情绪状态，所以我们的情绪状态会影响我们是否去纹身，然后一旦我们去纹身了，这又会产生进一步的影响。这就像一个循环，这就是为什么纹身上瘾是因为纹身的过程让我们产生某种感觉。任何改变我们情绪的事情，使我们把一项活动与立即感觉更好联系起来，都有可能让人上瘾。你知道，例如，酒精让我们感觉不那么焦虑，更有活力，这种情感联系使它让人上瘾。安非他命给我们带来巨大的冲击，让我们感到快乐。
Gambling makes us feel fulfilled by possibility. Tattoos bring us a sense of control. And according to that same study, they also make us feel better about how we look. They make us feel more at peace with our past. And they can make our lives feel more purposeful and significant. That is a very addictive feeling. I think a lot of us would do a lot of things to feel. happy in who we are, to feel at peace with our past, to feel meaningful in our life. That's pretty
赌博让我们从可能性中感到满足。纹身给我们带来一种控制感。根据同一项研究，它们也让我们对自己的外表感觉更好。它们让我们对自己的过去感到更平静。它们可以让我们的生活感觉更有目的性和意义。这是一种非常让人上瘾的感觉。我想我们很多人都会做很多事情来感觉自己很快乐，对自己过去感到平静，在生活中感到有意义。这相当
addictive. Therefore, getting tattoos is also addictive. It's a common experience I've heard from tattoo artists that they will get a client who has never had a tattoo before. They will give them their first tattoo and then a month later, this person will come back and have like dozens. Because the process for them is so emotionally satisfying. Some of that comes down, to our experiences with pain. Yes, we mostly want to avoid it. That's how we're hardwired. But there are some people who actually find it quite pleasurable and quite, it brings
让人上瘾。因此，纹身也是会上瘾的。我从纹理师那里听说过一种常见的情况，他们会接待一个从未有过纹身的客户。他们会给他们纹第一个纹身，然后一个月后，这个人会回来纹几十个。因为这个过程对他们来说在情感上太令人满意了。其中一部分归结于我们对痛苦的经历。是的，我们大多数时候都想避免它。这就是我们的天性。但有些人实际上觉得它相当愉快，而且相当，它带来了
about quite a sense of relief. Some people find catharsis in the process of getting a tattoo. You know, there's like this painful experience that then provides a really amazing result. it lets out pain that they may be feeling internally. All of this actually creates a lot of enjoyment that we associate with the process. We can also get quote unquote addicted to tattooing because of the role of two chemicals in our body, adrenaline and endorphins. Endorphins I'm just using as a general way of saying pleasant chemical messages.
一种解脱感。有些人从纹身的过程中找到了宣泄。你知道，就像这种痛苦的经历，然后带来了非常惊人的结果。它释放了他们内心可能感受到的痛苦。所有这些实际上创造了许多我们与这个过程联系在一起的快乐。我们也会因为我们体内的两种化学物质——肾上腺素和内啡肽的作用，而对纹身产生所谓的“上瘾”。我只是用内啡肽作为表达愉快化学信息的通用方式。
So the anticipation of and the pain that we experience from tattooing, that can lead to an adrenaline rush. This will naturally create a feeling of almost euphoria. Now, the adrenaline that is released in response to pain is meant to lessen the painful experience. But it actually means that we begin to associate the act of getting tattooed with, you know, a lot of warm and fuzzy feelings. Given, you know, the level of anticipation with any,
因此，我们对纹身的期待和所经历的痛苦，会导致肾上腺素激增。这自然会产生一种几乎是欣快感的感觉。现在，为了应对疼痛而释放的肾上腺素是为了减轻痛苦的体验。但它实际上意味着我们开始把纹身的行为与许多温暖而模糊的感觉联系在一起。考虑到对任何第一次经历的期待水平，
first experience, that adrenaline rush is going to be heightened. So the first time you get a tattoo, you are going to experience the largest adrenaline rush from the specific activity that you will ever experience. But people will continue to seek that rush. And that is why we can perhaps explain people who come back and come back and come back. It looks like an addiction, but it's more them chasing a specific feeling. Now, after getting a tattoo, our body will also naturally release endorphins to soothe our pain, to target inflammation. That also feels amazing.
那种肾上腺素的激增将会加剧。因此，当你第一次纹身时，你将从这项特定的活动中体验到你将经历的有史以来最大的肾上腺素激增。但人们会继续寻求那种激增。这就是为什么我们或许可以解释那些不断回来的人。这看起来像是一种瘾，但更像是他们在追逐一种特定的感觉。现在，在纹身后，我们的身体也会自然释放内啡肽来舒缓我们的疼痛，针对炎症。这也感觉好极了。
Some of the endorphins that we'll be experiencing are natural opioids, natural pain relievers that we know are extremely addictive. So that combination of the rush of adrenaline and then the emotional and physical comfort of endorphins may encourage us to keep going back. Now, this can be a dangerous process. And something that always comes up in discussions about tattoos is regret. If you're getting tattoo after tattoo after tattoo, are you making the best decisions?
我们将经历的一些内啡肽是天然阿片类药物，我们知道这是极其容易上瘾的天然止痛药。因此，肾上腺素激增与内啡肽带来的情感和身体安慰的结合，可能会鼓励我们不断回头。现在，这可能是一个危险的过程。在关于纹身的讨论中经常出现的一件事就是后悔。如果你一个接一个地纹身，你是在做出最好的决定吗？
Are you being wise about what you want on your body permanently? Now, this is always going to come into this discussion. And you'll frequently hear it from like older generations or people who feel uncertain about tattoos. They'll ask you, like, are you sure you want this on your body forever? Like, you know that this is forever, right? Are you sure that 30 year old you or 50 year old you or 80 year old you is that version of yourself going to love it as much as you do now? Like, how do you know this is a smart decision? I'm going to answer that question for you right here right now. You don't. You don't. And there is potential regret in absolutely everything.
你对你想永久留在身上的东西做出明智的选择吗？现在，这总是会进入这个讨论。你经常会从老一辈人或对纹身感到不确定的人那里听到这句话。他们会问你，比如，你确定你想把这个一辈子都留在身上吗？就像，你知道这是永远的，对吧？你确定30岁的你、50岁的你或80岁的你，那个版本的自己会像现在的你一样喜欢它吗？比如，你怎么知道这是一个明智的决定？我现在就在这里回答你的问题。你不知道。你不知道。而且绝对每件事都有潜在的后悔。
So chances are you might look at that tattoo at some point and say, that wasn't the best decision. But I don't think we need to fear, regret all that much. I don't think it's actually the worst thing that you can ever experience. I even think about the tattoos that I don't like now. I still enjoy them for what they meant to me back then. They're kind of like scars in a way. You know, they make a good story.
所以很有可能你在某个时刻看着那个纹身会说，那不是最好的决定。但我认为我们没必要那么害怕后悔。我认为这实际上并不是你能经历的最糟糕的事情。我甚至想到了我现在不喜欢的纹身。我仍然喜欢它们在当时对我的意义。在某种程度上，它们有点像伤疤。你知道，它们讲述了一个好故事。
They tell something about my experience. and they bring me a very strange but very valued connection with my past self. Like I can tap into exactly what she was thinking at that time, which I find quite special. And, you know, tattoos are going to change as you get older. They aren't going to look the same. They're going to be shaped by age. And that is something that you should be remembering. But also these days, like, they're not permanent.
它们讲述了我的经历。它们带给我一种非常奇怪但非常宝贵的与过去的自己的联系。就像我可以准确地探知她当时在想什么，我觉得这相当特别。而且，你知道，随着你变老，纹身也会改变。它们看起来不会一样了。它们将被年龄所塑造。这是你应该记住的事情。但现在这些东西，也不是永久的。
I saw that image of Pete Davidson recently. when I was in LA like I saw the billboard that he did for a reformation like all of his tattoos gone like it's possible it's expensive but it's possible probably not what you should be considering though like if you're getting a tattoo and you're thinking oh whatever I can remove it someday not the mindset you should go in with because it is still a painful process and it still will leave a mark and like this is you should be thinking of it as permanent. If you want to get like a semi-permanent tattoo like go and get those ones that you can like put on with a wet cloth. Like if you're going and thinking I can get this removed one day, you know the easiest way for that to happen is to
我最近看到了皮特·戴维森的那张照片，当我在洛杉矶时，我看到了他为Reformation做的广告牌——他所有的纹身都不见了——这是可能的，这很昂贵，但这是可能的。不过，这可能不是你应该考虑的，如果你去纹身，并且想着，噢，管他呢，我总有一天可以把它洗掉，这不是你应该抱有的心态，因为这仍然是一个痛苦的过程，它仍然会留下痕迹，你应该把它当作永久的。如果你想弄一个半永久的纹身，那就去弄那些可以用湿布贴上的。如果你去的时候想着我总有一天可以把它洗掉，你知道最简单的方法就是
just not get it right now. So I want to briefly talk about some tips for making the right decision about a tattoo because it's important. You know if you want to get one I think that's amazing. I really like mine. I find them like very decorative, very fun, good conversation starters, but you want to make smart decisions. Like, you don't want your first tattoo to be like an all-out, like, snake down your entire body. Or maybe you do, but this is what you should be thinking about. The most common reasons people regret their tattoos, according to a recent piece of research, is that it was impulsive. So around 35% of people say, I regret it because it was impulsive. it didn't have a significant meaning or they thought it would make them look cool and it doesn't.
现在就不要去纹。所以我想简单谈谈一些关于如何对纹身做出正确决定的建议，因为这很重要。你知道，如果你想纹一个，我认为这太棒了。我真的很喜欢我的纹身。我发现它们非常有装饰性，非常有趣，是很好的谈话切入点，但你想做出明智的决定。比如，你不会希望你的第一个纹身是一条盘在你全身的蛇。或者你也许想，但这就是你应该考虑的事情。根据最近的一项研究，人们后悔纹身最常见的原因是它是一时冲动。所以大约35%的人说，我后悔是因为这是一时冲动。它没有重大的意义，或者他们以为这会让他们看起来很酷，但其实并没有。
What we do find is the more thoughtful and careful you are about a tattoo, the less likely you are to regret it. So if you are thinking about getting something on your skin, before you do, print off that tattoo, the tattoo design that you have, put it somewhere that you'd see it every single day to make. make sure you don't get sick of it. And I think it's like recommended to do this for like three to six months. You know, if this is a tattoo you genuinely want and then you're going to love, you're still going to want it in six months. You're still going to want it in a year. And this is a great
我们确实发现，你对纹身越是深思熟虑、小心谨慎，你后悔的可能性就越小。因此，如果你正在考虑在皮肤上弄点什么，在动手之前，把那个纹身打印出来，把你拥有的纹身设计放在你每天都能看到的地方，以确保你不会看腻。我想建议这样做三到六个月。你知道，如果这是一个你真心想要并且会一直喜欢的纹身，你六个月后还是会想要它。你一年后还是会想要它。这是一个很好的
insurance for you to say, okay, if I had to look at this every single day, would I still want it? Secondly, when you start, start small, start with somewhere not visible. Also just important to see how your body reacts to it, whether like you actually like the process and you're not halfway through a tattoo in so much pain, regretting it and it's somewhere really, really visible. I think that's just wise. Don't get tattoos when you're drunk. Oh my lord.
对你的保证，让你说，好吧，如果我每天都要看这个，我还会想要它吗？其次，当你开始时，从小处着手，从一个不显眼的地方开始。这也是为了看看你的身体对它的反应，看看你是否真的喜欢这个过程，而不是纹了一半痛苦不堪，后悔了，而且位置还非常非常显眼。我认为这很明智。不要在喝醉的时候去纹身。天哪。
I have friends who have done this. not only did they end up looking really bad because their blood was really thin so it leaked but it really comes down to the impulsive nature of this this might be a controversial one and it might sound hypocritical considering i got like my first tattoo when i was 18 but if i had to go back i would say don't get a tattoo before you turn 20 please like i don't know why that feels like a good distinction, but the longer you can wait, the better. I think getting a tattoo young, and I still think like 18, 19, 20 is quite young. I'm not saying it's going to increase your chances of regretting it. I'm just saying that getting a tattoo a little bit older might
我有一些朋友这样做过。不仅因为他们的血很稀导致流血，看起来很糟糕，而且这确实归结于它的冲动性。这可能是一个有争议的观点，考虑到我18岁时就有了第一个纹身，这听起来可能很虚伪，但如果让我回去，我会说不要在20岁之前纹身，求求了，我不知道为什么这感觉像是一个很好的分界线，但你能等得越久越好。我认为年轻时纹身，我仍然认为18、19、20岁还很年轻。我并不是说这会增加你后悔的机会。我只是说，稍微大一点再纹身可能会
reduce your chances of regretting it. And finally, be safe. And if it costs more, that's not a bad thing. This is like a permanent accessory for you. Think about how much you would spend on a really nice pair of jeans, really nice pair of shoes on a handbag. Like this, think about cost per wear here. You're going to be wearing this every single day of your life. So it is an investment. Go to a good tattoo artist. I have seen so many terrible tattoos in my day and on Reddit and on Pinterest and on Instagram. You don't want to be that just because you want the tattoo really badly right now. You will still want it in three months when you have a little bit more money. Trust me, it really makes all the difference. I am so lucky that one of my best
减少你后悔的机会。最后，要注意安全。如果它更贵，那不是坏事。这就像是你的一个永久配饰。想想你会花多少钱买一条很好的牛仔裤、一双很好的鞋子或一个手提包。就像这样，在这里想想每次穿着的成本。你每天的生活中都会穿戴它。所以这是一笔投资。去找一个好的纹师。我见过我这辈子以及在Reddit、Pinterest和Instagram上见过无数糟糕的纹身。你不想成为那种人，仅仅因为你现在非常想要这个纹身。当你手头宽裕一点的时候，三个月后你依然会想要它。相信我，这真的有着天壤之别。我很幸运，我的一个最好的
friends is a tattoo artist and I trust her more than anyone and you can really tell the difference between someone who is really passionate about their craft and does everything right and someone who is doing tattoos for $5 at like somewhere on a strip mall. So those would be my most significant important tips. Also maybe some advice to younger Gemma, to baby Gemma around what she should have done differently. You know what though? I want to finish out this episode by saying it is your body.
朋友是一名纹身师，我比任何人都要信任她。你真的能看出一个对自己的手艺充满热情、把每件事都做好的人，和一个在商场购物中心里收5美元帮人纹身的人之间的区别。所以这些将是我最重要、最重要的建议。可能也是对年轻的杰玛、对年幼的杰玛的一些建议，告诉她本该做哪些不同的事情。不过你知道吗？我想以这句话来结束这一集：这是你的身体。
It is your body to have regrets about. It is your body to modify. It is your body to modify. It is your body to express and to demonstrate with and to decorate. So yes, make smart decisions, but don't consider disappointing people as part of it. Don't consider what other people are going to think too much so in this consideration of getting a tattoo. If it's something that's important to you, if it's something that you think will ground you, if it's something that you think will help with healing and will, you know, perhaps psychologically shift to how you
这是你的身体，由你来承担后悔。这是你的身体，由你来改变。这是你的身体，由你来改变。这是你的身体，由你来表达、展示和装饰。所以是的，做出明智的决定，但不要把让人失望作为其中的一部分。在考虑纹身时，不要过多考虑别人的想法。如果这是对你很重要的事，如果这是你认为能让你脚踏实地的事，如果这是你认为有助于康复的事，并且（你知道的）可能会在心理上改变你看待自己的方式，
see yourself, that is always going to be worth it in my mind. And if you just like it and you want a tattoo, do it. Like, you're young. If you're worried about other people's opinions, get it someone no one can see, make it quite an intimate part of you. I actually think it's quite a beautiful ride of passage. It's something that was on my bucket list when I'm a kid. I'm glad that I've done it. And for all the thoughts about it, again, it just comes down to personal preference. and what's going to make you feel good and what's going to make you feel happy in the form and the vessel that you're in.
在我看来，这永远是值得的。如果你就是喜欢它，想要一个纹身，那就去做吧。就像，你还年轻。如果你担心别人的看法，把它纹在别人看不到的地方，让它成为你非常私密的一部分。我实际上认为这是一个非常美丽的成年礼。这是我小时候愿望清单上的事情。我很高兴我做到了。对于所有关于它的想法，再次强调，这完全归结于个人喜好，以及什么能让你感觉良好，什么能让你在你所在的这个躯壳里感到快乐。
So I hope you enjoy this episode. Now, the people who make it this far know that they will always get a little emoji. So for your emoji, choose the emoji that you would most want tattooed on your body. Let's confuse the people who don't listen to the end, but then pretend they do because they see the emoji. What are you most likely to want to get from the little emoji list?
所以我希望你喜欢这一集。现在，收听到这里的人都知道他们总能得到一个小表情符号。所以对于你的表情符号，选择你最想纹在身上的表情符号。让我们把那些没有听到最后却假装听了的人搞糊涂吧，因为他们看到了表情符号。从小表情符号列表中，你最有可能想选哪个？
And if you have a tattoo, let me know. Do you regret any of your tattoos and why? Let's kind of share the word, share the knowledge, so someone else might not make the same mistake. I've already told you mine. I regret two of mine, my 22 and my one post breakup. But I still love them. So I hope you still love yours as well.
如果你有纹身，请告诉我。你后悔过你的任何纹身吗？为什么？让我们分享一下语言，分享一下知识，这样别人就不会犯同样的错误了。我已经告诉过你们我的了。我后悔其中的两个，我的“22”和分手后纹的那一个。但我仍然爱它们。所以我希望你们也依然爱你们的纹身。
But please share below. make sure that you are following and you leave a five-star review. Also, if you have further questions, stories, I don't know, comments about this episode. You can always message me at that psychology podcast on Instagram. I'd love to hear from you. Until next time though, stay safe. Please be kind. Be gentle to yourself.
但请在下方分享。确保你关注并留下了五星好评。此外，如果你有更多的问题、故事，或者对这一集有什么评论。你随时可以在Instagram上发私信给我@thatpsychology podcast。我很想听到你们的意见。不过在下次之前，保重。请友善点。对自己好一点。
And I will talk to you very, very soon. On the Look Back at a podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
我很快就会和大家再次交流。在Look Back at a podcast节目中。1979年，对我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家，来弄清楚我们是如何在其中生存下来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Gang.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·甘（Kier Gang）主持的Learn the Hard Way。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused. of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人带着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。您对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，欧文斯女士，对吗？我对测试动过手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是Love Trapped。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即TWO%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由真人制作。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。